se abre una nueva fase de política en
italia con el mandato para formar un
nuevo gobierno asignado por el
presidente sergio mataré la a mario
draghi este economista alto funcionario
italiano de 73 años fue gobernador del
banco de italia por cinco años y
presidente del banco central europeo
entre 2011 y 2019 a partir de ahora su
misión será la de convencer a las
diferentes fuerzas políticas del país
para que apoyen un gobierno
institucional de unión nacional que
cuente con un amplio apoyo en el
parlamento italiano que le permita tomar
decisiones concretas en un momento de
crisis sanitaria social y económica sin
precedentes en el país la misión de
draghi no será fácil por un lado podría
contar con el apoyo del partido
democrático y del partido forza italia
de silvio berlusconi pero por otro lado
será difícil que el movimiento 5
estrellas' lo apoye ya que no ve con
buenos ojos su pasado de banquero y
tampoco se sabe cuál será la posición
oficial adoptada por la liga
el principal partido
derecha italiana